هذا هو المقر الرئيسي لـ ping in
Phoenix arizona من
خلال هذه الأبواب ، وهو ببساطة
موطن لواحد من أكثر المضارب شهرة في كل
العصور ،
وقد ساعد نجاحه في جعل الشركة
علامة تجارية رائدة في عالم الجولف
في أرض المصنع قام الموظفون
بتجميع أحدث خزانات ping
تم العثور على ثمار كل عملهم على
مقربة من مكاوي وسائقين ،
لقد رأينا بالتأكيد بعض الأشياء المدهشة
على مر السنين في لعبة الجولف الحية ،
لكنني لست متأكدًا من أنه يمكنك أن تكون
مستعدًا حقًا لما نحن على وشك أن نشهده
وراء هذا الباب المقبب ، لذا فإنه
لامتياز حقيقي أن
أرى هذه الغرفة على أغلفة المجلات
على مر السنين
الآن أن أراها شخصيًا
[موسيقى]
مرحبًا بكم في لعبة Fort Knox الخاصة بالجولف
والمعروفة أيضًا باسم ping's gold pault vault ،
إنه تقليد في الشركة في كل
مرة  يتم الفوز بدورة احترافية باستخدام
مضرب بينج ، تم عمل نسخة طبق الأصل مطلية بالذهب
حتى الآن ، يوجد أكثر من
2800 مضرب مضرب بالإضافة إلى عدد قليل من الأوتاد في
حالة ما إذا كنت تعتقد أنه لم يكن هناك ما يكفي من
اللمعان.  Azing John ، إنها مثل رحلة إلى
حارة الذاكرة ، كما تعلم ، أعتقد أن هناك 47
مضاربًا من Sevi Balustero هنا ، وهو أمر
غير واقعي ، لقد أحب إجابة ping ، ألم يكن
متأكدًا من أنه فعل ذلك
في مكتبه فوق قبو
John Solheim يدير ping بنفس الطريقة تمامًا
مثل  قام والده المبتكر كارستن
منذ جيل
مضى بأفكاره حول الطريقة التي
يجب أن تتم بها الأشياء ، كما تعلم أننا نريد القيام
بالأشياء بالطريقة الصحيحة ما لم نتمكن من
تحسين المنتج ،
فلن نطرحه في السوق ، فنحن لسنا فقط
جلبها إلى السوق
للحصول على البيع الأولي في نوع الأشياء
التي نريد توفير منتج أفضل كما
تعلم أننا نفعل ذلك على طريقتنا التي هي في الحقيقة طريقة
كارستن في الخمسينيات من القرن الماضي ، كارستن سولهايم
مهندس ميكانيكي مولود في النرويج وحريص  أراد لاعب الغولف
تحسين وضعه وخفض
درجاته من خلال تطبيق ما
أسماه أبسط قوانين الفيزياء
والميكانيكا لجعل مضربًا أكثر كفاءة
بعد تصميم بعض النماذج الأولية في عام 1966 ، قام
كارستن ببناء إجابة ping
بدلاً من  ربط العمود
بكعب النصل
وضعه سولهايم في اتجاه المركز
ونقل معظم وزن
رأس المضرب إلى
المحيط ، وسرعان ما تم اكتشاف التصميم الثوري
وبحلول السبعينيات حصل أكثر من 50 في المائة من
لاعبي جولة pga على إجابة ping
في حقيبتهم
حتى الآن ، تم الفوز بأكثر من 500 بطولة للمحترفين
باستخدام تعديلات مختلفة
للنادي
في عام 1968 ، قدم سولهايم نفس
مبادئ الوزن المحيط للمكاوي ،
وسرعان ما اتبعت الشركات المصنعة للمعدات الأخرى
ابتكاراته وأصبح
معيارًا صناعيًا ،
لقد كان بالتأكيد شخصًا
مختلفًا.  بالنسبة لوقته ، أعني أنه
كان ويلسون سبالدينج سيطر على
السوق ، ولكن نظرًا لحقيقة
أننا قمنا بعمل جيد ، فقد فتح الباب
أمام أمثال callaway و taylormade
وبعض الشركات الأخرى للدخول أيضًا
[Music]
توفي كارستن في  عام 2000 البالغ من العمر 88 عامًا.
لا يزال ping اليوم شركة تديرها عائلة
بينما نجل كارستن
هو الرئيس التنفيذي نجل جون هو نائب الرئيس التنفيذي
للصحافة  من المؤكد أن هناك نوعًا ما
على المدى الطويل مثل أننا
نستعد لإطلاقنا الآن ، لذلك هناك ضغط
يأتي مع ذلك ولكن على
أساس يومي لدينا نظام جيد
ونشهد باستمرار
تحسينات على  نطاق القيادة من
خلال لاعبنا الذي يختبر اختبار pingman الخاص بنا ،
لذلك لم نكن حقًا في
هذا المأزق حيث لا توجد لدينا أفكار جيدة ،
فلدينا دائمًا أفكار جيدة